est-ce que tu regrettes parfois d'être
youtubeur non un imposteur avec DiCaprio
et Brad pit est-ce que c'est possible
non tu as peur d'avoir 30 ans non twitch
c'est mieux que
YouTube non l'argent fait-il le bonheur
euh
oui un GP explorer 3 est-ce que c'est
envisageable
euh oui tu
pass il y a des invités sur ta chaîne
que tu as trouvé ultra relou non tu
regrettes parfois ton pseudo non
tuécoutes time time en soirée non inox
il va réussir à gravir l'eververest
ouais si on fait un Mario Kart tu me bas
oui faux c'est faux c'est faux c'est
faux tu as peur de l'avenir non tu
confierais ta voiture à villebrequin non
non non tu es déjà un boomer pour TikTok
non tu aimerais être invisible parfois
ouais tu pourrais faire daner avec les
stars non tu penses être encore numéro 1
sur YouTube dans 2 ans j'en sais rien